hey what's up I'm here I'm sitting in
traffic frustrated because Ellie is
terrible traffic um anyway the sheenies
new show here and it's called a big shot
live it's all online and
I figured hey I'm here you guys are here
I'm just gonna go visit your office all
right I think this is the office
google map circle here
burbank so they said they said they said
he'll be right hi i am Justine Justine
yes just seen iJustine I have an eye in
front my name I just younger I see Brad
a hot road I'm acanthosis give it up
women yes was with Brian are you all
yours yoga instructor yes okay you know
the me call him and tell me you're here
okay I do not showing me how to do um
what is it like that the pose of the
mountain oh well I can I can show you
Brian your yogurt you're never done yoga
and man those of something like this oh
I he Brian somebody quit doing yoga I
say no I am here to help him no stretch
stretch you might need that looks a
little stressed out lately man I'm can
talk about like that xiv it I mean can I
come in come in to and learn what you
guys are doing yeah is that alright with
you or is it is it me that's cool I so
take my shoes off if we're gonna we're
gonna yoga and yoga mats we never gave
carpeting so it's it's just a soft and
um but fun that's great so we're makes a
cheap guns what's the camera for oh this
is uh oh boy um sometimes I have this
thing where I film my life I film
everything that I do is like a real
world like a yoga documentary like a
yoga documentary real world' real world'
style with this little camera right do
you think me i can just go in front it's
okay i got me a shirt yeah hey Brian are
you are you are you dressed so i have
somebody on your yoga instructor
maybe we should use like a code word for
are you dress like has the eagle landed
can I come in yeah you're gonna
instructor jet was just Justine hi hey
hi I'm Justine to see hi hi hi ooh way
we do I was at yoga I I don't know you
I'm sorry no he does he knows me yeah I
think we've we've would I've done yoga
with you I hit me mother okay I'm
missing some of my vertebrae I can't do
yoga well I know but I I made a special
program for you to help you regrow your
vertebrae to regenerate the subluxation
hurry messenger well my name is Amanda I
mean uh oh I'm Justine your Amanda yeah
what are you doing you're just gonna
listen Big Shot live I'm not afraid to
use this phone to call firstly I want
it's so big shot live I this is what it
is this is it no we discuss this like
seriously okay look I can sing and I can
dance I'm even like host a TV show if
need be I understand all you have to do
his upload a video and we'll check it
out and you'll get the votes and we'll
see how you know works out which is all
for me it's not enough to me we're just
gonna you know what just gonna say
website if you just go to chill a
meeting don't we're not know i'm meeting
with me meeting haha hey I've never I
don't like to do this to women but I'm
gonna have to turn to you hit women no I
don't hit them at no i turn my name I I
kind of I like the letter stray bead ehh
i do you want her to me I never you're
under main hope but it's just for my
hubby oh it is my hobby what are you
going on right somebody please just lift
can I just haven't mean let's just we're
having a medium iced abuse well this
feels good let's sit down oh wow we just
how conversation oh listen to me do you
want to die you guys gotta stop this
[__] I mean we got a serious production
company down here yeah we're doing work
you can't come in here and film and be
making all this damn noise disturbing
our people it's something you got I got
six offices doing I understand and it's
like you guys are getting out of control
because you need a stylist safe to do
this that's tricky not me wrong that's
just listen call Amanda will schedule
meeting the guy hates me I don't want to
get kicked out can we just vote up my
videos nope can you just boat my video
please just up like